There’s a new Game of Thrones Season 7 promo
out now called Long Walk.
Let’s have a quick look.
So the promo focusses on three main characters
– Jon Snow, Daenerys Targaryen and Cersei
Lannister, who each walk and take their place
at their respective seats of power – Jon
as King in the North in Winterfell, Cersei
as Queen of Westeros on the Iron Throne, and
Dany at her seat on the island of Dragonstone
– from there she hopes to invade and conquer
Westeros.
Dragonstone has a lot of history and symbolism
for Dany and her family, the Targaryens.
Dany was born at Dragonstone, and centuries
before, her great-great-great-great-great-great-great-great-great-great-great-grandfather
Aegon the Conqueror left from Dragonstone
to take Westeros and establish the Targaryen
dynasty – go watch that video.
So Dany is walking in the footsteps of her
ancient ancestor, it’s by the right of Aegon’s
conquest that Dany means to claim her crown
– though Cersei might have something to
say about that.
Cersei has walked too, she’s been shamed
and beaten down for her crimes, but this seems
to have only made her angrier, crueller, more
dangerous.
After the deaths of her three children, Cersei
has nothing to lose but her Throne – so
she won’t easily let it go.
Jon Snow is also walking, which is impressive
given the state he was in last season.
Jon has experienced death, felt the cold,
and he knows about the real threat to Westeros.
He’ll be using his power as King in the
North to try to convince everyone to stop
with the political squabbling and to focus
on the true enemy – cause when the candles
go out, and the eyes all close, a blue eye
opens, an eye of the white walkers.
This particular eye looks like it belongs
to a giant – look at the big nose – so
this might be Wun Wun, the giant who died
at the Battle of the Bastards.
Looks like he’s been raised as a zombie
to fight for the walkers.
In the books, all sorts of creatures join
the army of the dead – there’s a zombie
bear, zombie birds , talk of dead things in
the water . It seems that anything that can
die can become an undead servant of the walkers.
Some fans speculate we could see a zombie
dragon – George Martin did write a book
called The Ice Dragon, after all.
Point is, the walkers are clearly set up as
the main threat to Westeros this next season.
So this promo, the Long Walk evokes not only
where the characters are going, but also where
they’ve been.
Jon, Dany and Cersei have each come a long
way since Season One.
Jon Snow was a know-nothing naïve baby-faced
bastard boy, not so long ago – but soon
became a battle-hardened leader of the Night’s
Watch.
He was a corpse for a bit but is now the King
of all the North.
Dany was the political pawn of her crazy brother
Viserys, but became the dragon queen of Meereen.
She was for a while a Dothraki captive, but
is now a powerful conqueror.
Cersei started as a cruel capricious incest
queen, and now she’s, well, she’s about
the same really, but she certainly is angrier,
and now is the Queen of Westeros.
These three have all walked a long way.
They’ve each been brought low, but are now
more experienced, mature, and powerful than
ever were before.
This is like the point in a video game where
your character’s fully levelled up, maxed
out, and ready to face the final boss – in
this case white walkers, and winter, and the
night that never ends.
Thanks for watching.
Make sure to subscribe and to turn on post
notifications so you don’t miss a video
– just press that bell button.
And thanks to the Patrons, including Sarun
Pinyarat, Cole Handel Lane, Debby Lu, Molly
Manning, Tony Onodi, and nynke.
Cheers.